[Music]
delighted to be here with you today
and looking forward to this for a very
long time so welcome what brought you to
Los Angeles what brought me to Los
Angeles well Brandi Carlile's singing
Joni Mitchell oh there you go well
that's as good a reason as any and you
but I was it did it live up to the lived
up to the hype
actually there were parts of it that
lived up to the hype in unexpected ways
Brandi Carlile was so nervous to perform
blue in front of her idol
you know Joni Mitchell was there Sir
Elton John was there I had seats behind
you know I didn't have the best seats
but I was close but I could I had a
perfect view of all the people all the
famous people sitting in the front
couple rows you got to see this
performance so it was just a trip to see
Brandy's body language from behind most
of the time but she was and that she was
very open about her tension about it
she's like I am really nervous about
this you know
oh yeah Joni Mitchell's the living
legend I mean she the way Brandi
described her I think is true it's like
living in the time of Beethoven or
Rembrandt but in music and we live at
the same time as Joni Mitchell and
probably not for much longer so you have
a deep Joni Mitchell fandom streak I do
I mean she's her album blue she's um
she's spectacular and my whole family
loves Joni Mitchell and my dad is the
one that introduced me to Joni and he
introduced Jessie to Joni when Jessie
and I first started dating on this camp
trip and Jessie was super nervous and my
dad essentially told Jessie he should
start getting into Joni Mitchell cuz the
ladies like it he was giving him tips he
said it in a much more crude way than
that but uh uh but it usually had to be
coming right yeah he has a nice respect
for Joni Mitchell ah yeah that's cool
well I'm not you you've got on an
airplane to come and see that I did yeah
birthday slash Mother's Day present for
my mom went to a fancy restaurant and
just we just had a really kind of out of
the ordinary experience for us
so it was very special cool and you grew
up around here I did you know Santa
Clarita and I was just noting on the
drive up here how this area is where I
used to go with my dad when he would
take me to work
wake me up at 4:30 go down to the sets
of dr. Quinn Medicine Woman at paramount
ranch and my sister and I would play
around and whatever like western
buildings weren't being used that day
for filming and imagine that we were
Prairie people yeah he was a prop master
right I'll do that
no he passed four years ago but he's
like he was 30-something years I mean he
got started building sets for concerts
of all the kind of great bands of the
you know 60s and 70s in his late teen
years and then he went in the Army for a
few years went to Germany came back and
then he started working for Hollywood in
the Union Building sets right paramount
ranch is super cool but it's gone now
baby yeah completely burned in the fire
people who are listening might might
recognize it from West world they shoot
all that all that kind of people western
the other West the Western towns don't
was all done it and that white church is
is from West world as well yeah so I
think the church is still there but
everything else is gone and they haven't
rebuilt it yet wow what a trip yeah that
was it's just one of those moments when
I'm driving with my mom and she tells me
that you're having this nice little
memory about a place that was important
to you as a kid and it's like oh by the
way it burned down you're like oh okay
all right everything everything's
burning down around here yeah yeah fire
this past weekend yeah and I want to
track like your whole personal story
because it's super interesting but
there's so much going on you're running
in track and field right now it's insane
like I can't even keep up with all the
crazy news and there's somebody who's
yes you're retired but you're very much
an insider and you've been outspoken and
have lots of opinions on all of these
things so I'm kind of excited to hear
your take on all the goings on well
great I better take a few sips coffee
let's do this I mean we can start with
Kipchoge YZ 159 I mean what do you what
do you make yes just this past weekend
didn't livestream it I don't even
remember what I was doing think work
events stuff but certainly followed it
and I mean it's amazing it was amazing
to see it done even in the context of
you know performance enhancing shoe
technology that maybe shouldn't be legal
for performance or I don't know all the
pacing and stuff it's still magical to
see somebody going for it and kept oh
he's such a lovable character like he
seems like such a beautiful guy his and
he is he really feels deeply and has a
way of expressing himself that it feels
pure to me and I think without Kip chogi
being the hero of that story this I
don't think it would work I don't think
it would hold much interest yeah I think
it was lindsay crouse who tweeted
something like the best part was seeing
him accelerate across the finish line
and then speed up to hug his wife yes
yeah it wasn't that finish line clip was
the only clip I really saw yeah me too
and it wasn't it was so cool I mean just
bliss on his face you know and it's also
really it shows you how much adrenaline
you experience by how little effort he
looked like he was feeling at the end I
mean who knows I mean he and I think
it's you know kind of canvassing the
internet reaction to this whole thing
has been interesting like I think that
you can you can appreciate kind of the
beauty and orchestration that went into
doing something that had never been done
before
while also understanding that there's
artifice involved and there's these
crazy shoes we don't even know what's
inside this shoe and and you know all
the pacing and all the machinations that
went into making it possible like we can
entertain both of those I mean it's a
magic show it just reminds me of the big
public displays of the famous musicians
and uh you know making the Statue of
Liberty Liberty disappear or you know
any of these things the think tanks in
the middle of plazas you know they're
all orchestrated for entertainment if
you know what you're getting into cool
you know yeah and and I think it'll be
interesting to see how long it takes
before we see 159 in a real race like I
would imagine
that the impact of that display will
accelerate that happening because it
changes people's perspective and belief
about what's possible absolutely not you
see that across all industries you have
to see it to be it and yeah unless you
keep Shogun you just be it but for most
of us it helps to have it to see it done
and you know there are the valid
criticisms too there one of the things
that sits with me as a woman is there's
so often this kind of really important
milestone that starts with men you know
the sub-2 marathon the sub four mile and
the the beginning of rallying around
these barriers is always on the men's
side and then we sort of search for the
female equivalent kind of after the fact
in like Oh equality right what could we
do here that is equally exciting or
transcendent culturally to get people
Pumped on the women's side and so it's
always a little bit tough on that you
know it's thinking about that and it's I
don't want to you know use it to take
away from what kept chogi did cuz
absolutely it's amazing but it is
enlightening to just see that when you
have the biggest sports brand in the
world deciding where they're gonna put
their marketing dollars it's mostly men
in those rooms and they're mostly
interested in the men's performances and
so that the ideas that naturally spring
up are around men's barriers and that's
just another example of that so there's
just another reason to get more women in
more of those rooms yeah well we did see
the eclipsing of Paula rod right let's
record this this weekend as well yeah
guy also onic on a crazy mysterious shoe
yes she is but nonetheless a world
record performance yeah that one's hard
for me to get excited about I think you
know she works with an agent who's been
associated with so many marathoners that
have tested positive for drugs and you
know it's just like the unfortunate
thing is this association if you
associate yourself with these people who
have so many ties to drugs and doping
and it's really difficult to appreciate
it
right now fully well I suspend believe
which which brings us to the next big
you know
engine running which is the Salazar you
know doping scandal oh and and what I
didn't know until I start digging into
you a little bit deeper over the past
couple days was your own little crime
semi brush with Salazar back in when was
that like 2015 or something like that
I've 2005 or 2005 right I read I read
David Epstein's ProPublica yeah he's on
that at the time
so can you yes I mean I know it's
ancient history but it's now it seems
really kind of fresh and relevant yeah
definitely I think it's interesting
because with all the conversations
around whistleblowers I don't know I
don't know if I classify I don't think I
do but it's just one of those I don't
really know where my story fits in it I
mean it was a little bit of an alarm
bell sounding I think yeah there's a
harbinger of what was to come
yeah and I knew that there was an
investigation underway
I knew they were obviously digging
around in Alberto's methods and I've
been thinking a lot about that time cuz
wouldn't that interview with ProPublica
started resurfacing when the Alberto
Salazar thing came out and I started
seeing my name back in I was feeling
nauseous because doing that interview
was really challenging it was a tough
decision for me to do not because I feel
that I cheated or deserve or was at risk
of I don't know it's hard to explain why
it was I guess it was just admitting to
the mindset of an athlete trying to be
the best and how you are then vulnerable
to the adults in your life and their
input on what it's going to take to be
the best and that I took a small step in
the direction and probably would have
taken many more if I had been in Nike
Oregon project I mean I I was like one
of the most promising athletes in
history coming out of Stanford and my
event and you know a lot of people
thought I had the kind of the complete
package to put help put distance running
back on the map I mean it's on the map
now but it wasn't when I was coming out
of college we had Dena casters medal in
Marathon
and meb's and but outside of those two
little moments we had had nothing right
for so long and and that was my whole
goal was to do that and so I came out of
Stanford and there was this sort of
emerging I don't know philosophy that
was in reaction to all the blood doping
so blood every every movement is sort of
a reaction to something else so blood
doping was becoming this big thing and
people reading about it and then the
flip side of that was how can we beat
the cheaters without crossing the line
like how can we outsmart the cheaters
using all the legal tools at our
disposal and this is the era of Paula
Radcliffe this is the era of Alberto
Salazar founding thank you organ project
and I really think that the intentions
at the time were I mean he said it
straight up in interviews before were to
use every single method on just on this
side of legal to be competitive with the
rest of the world and to put us on the
top of the stage and that wasn't
controversial at the time that was kind
of like a oh good idea way to use what
we've got which is science and
technology and smarts right and now when
we look at it with this 15-year lens
looking back all this concept of
marginal gains and going into grey areas
is very much in line with cheating we're
like oh that would be intent was to get
an unfair advantage therefore you know
it was against the spirit of the sport
and essentially that's where we are now
that's where I sit now with how I feel
about it I really feel that you
shouldn't do any of those things but
yeah at the time it wasn't I don't think
it was very clear and so I remember
being in that position of should I
should I sleep in an altitude tent
I do have asthma and have a prescription
for an inhaler should I take the
strongest dose possible to me year-round
even if I only need it seasonally you
know like these kind of questions of
like what where is the line and where
should it be
and it does get grey and murky I mean
there's there's on the one hand there's
things like cryotherapy and warm-up
techniques and I think you know sleeping
in an altitude tent is kind of a
standard practice for a lot of people
like I don't think people look at that
as being
super controversial but that seems
qualitatively different than hey you
have a little bit of asthma but let's
Trump it up and try to get the massive
dose and use it year-round yeah it was -
yeah just when your symptoms flare up
exactly and so in seeking guidance for
my asthma you know Alberto was the
person who knew a doctor in Portland who
had experience testing athletes and I
believe this doctor was a good doctor I
don't think the doctor has been it's not
like the dr. Brown case with thyroid
this asthma doctor has not been
implicated in anything but and all those
medications are now legal anyway but at
the time they were on the restricted
list you had to have a therapeutic use
exemption for certain kinds of inhalers
and yeah it was just a you know if you
went to your neighborhood allergist they
would just have you breathe in a tube
and go you don't have asthma
you're like no really though I do when I
run in cold weather or the 5k but they
couldn't simulate those conditions and
so you couldn't test appropriately an
extra you know exercise induced asthma
just anywhere so anyway that was kind of
how I ended up getting connected with
Alberto I was a top Nike athlete I lived
in Oregon or not where did I live at the
time maybe I live in California that
time anyway I was gonna be living in
Oregon but I had obviously connections
to Nike headquarters and he was starting
this thing in there out there and it was
like I was like one step removed so I
had access to some of it if I wanted it
but then I had VIN Lana as my coach who
really protected me I mean he when I
look back I'm so glad I was under his
guidance at the time is that I know
altitude tents are illegal but it's what
an altitude tent led to at that time so
if you were sleeping in an altitude 10
all the time and you were trying to
maintain this crazy level of training it
was really common to get run down
because you weren't sleeping as well you
know with altitude Ted well once you get
run down now suddenly you can go to the
doctor that test I roid and show that
your thyroid is suppressed right because
you're suddenly all your other values
are getting negatively impacted so I
always kind of started to or I'd always
I now see the altitude
through Nike organ project as a kind of
a gateway to other things and it did
facilitated my exhaustion really quickly
yeah and that led to a conversation with
inland Anna about thyroid because I had
heard about other athletes and Gaylen
rap and whoever having this thyroid
problem and I was like maybe I have a
thyroid problem he's like maybe you do
but maybe maybe you know you're just
tired because you're training really
hard and you're not sleeping properly
you're sleeping in this tent and maybe
you need to take responsibility for what
the limits of your body are and I was I
remember feeling really embarrassed
because I remember thinking like if I go
to this doctor that these guys are
seeing I'll probably get whatever
they're getting you know yeah and I
think what's interesting about this
experience that you had is that I mean
ultimately you had an ethical
compunction that allowed you to say like
this is this doesn't feel right to me
like there's there's like what's legally
okay and then there's you know our
internal kind of barometer around ethics
and you know that flared up for you and
you were like I'm stepping away from
this this doesn't feel right to me but I
think it speaks to how these things
happen like we tend to you know you know
from our armchairs cast aspersion and
judgment on these athletes that make the
wrong choice but we don't appreciate the
nuance of what leads up to it because it
is a very gradual slow thing where it's
one thing and then it's the next thing
and then before you know it you're
you've crossed that line but that line
seems imperceptible in the moment yeah
and I and that's why in the end I
decided to speak with David Epstein
because I felt that the conversations I
was hearing around the topics of dr.
Brown and the thyroid stuff or the tents
or the or Alberto's group all this stuff
I just felt like was turning so
black-and-white like any athlete that
could do anything is just evil and any
you know and and I was like it's so much
more complex it is so much more complex
and I've always believed that telling
personal narrative is kind of the is the
better way to help people understand the
complexity of something and and so I got
kind of offered myself out there even
though I knew it would result in some
skewering I
ended up getting a call from an old
competitor right when it came out who
chewed me out who was just like she took
it as you cheated and this and this and
like as a she I think she took it as I
had all these other things I must not
have admitted really there was nothing
else to the story but I remember taking
that call and just being like okay here
we go
like why did I even bother telling that
story is it going to be any good but I
do think that it helped contribute to a
conversation that a public conversation
a public understanding it's just one of
many stories that contributes to like
the dialogue around this the importance
of really fighting for ethical and clean
sport of learning what is and isn't okay
and what we want those that to look like
in the future you know the past is what
it is but I still do believe clean sport
is possible it's gonna be hard but it
needs to be nuanced our understanding of
the past and yeah we rely a lot on
whistleblowers too so no one's gonna
come out and talk about their
experiences if we have this black and
white view on everything right and it's
amazing that that you shared what you
shared way back in 2005 and here we are
in 2019 when this is finally getting
adjudicated and in between we have Steve
Magnus when when did Steve Magnus kind
of come out and publicly talk about that
l-carnitine thing that went I think it
was actually so it had this the story I
told us from 2005 but it was probably
between 2015 and 17 that I did the or
when I got published and then that was
similar to Steve so it was kind of
around we were all starting to tell our
stories because the rise of Nike organ
project and these performances that
seemed unbelievable and you know this
the stories that were kind of being
circulated within distance running of
what was going on there plus some of our
personal experiences you know I heard
some of the things about l-carnitine I
was like that's not hard for me to
believe or that all these athletes are
being tested for are being treated for
thyroid conditions and the medication
helps them lose weight before race sees
and I'm like that's not hard to believe
because of my experience with asthma and
my conversations with Alberto I I feel
felt like I understood the mindset and
so I just I I was concerned that I was
the biggest sports brand most
influential
Bart's brand putting their marketing
dollars behind this group in these
performances that had an ethos that was
really dangerous to clean sport that's
not okay
you know and it goes all the way to the
top does CEO being aware of the
testosterone cream and all of that and
yeah the email from Salazar to Lance
Armstrong you know there's a lot of
stuff that you know people all the way
to the top were privy to yeah they were
and it's it's one of those things around
innovation too and I don't know if you
have thought about it from that
perspective but I think that what
Alberto wanted to do with NOP was some
sort of parallel to what the Innovation
Lab looks like for Footwear right it was
let's innovate our approach to training
and coaching just the way we would
innovate
the fastest spike will look outside the
box we'll put a carbon play in it
whatever you do and and I think to me
that explains why there was so much
conversation with Mark Parker because it
it's and to me that does a line between
technological innovation and other kind
of you know less acceptable form you
know forward
yeah got kind of meshed yeah right I
think I mean it's not dissimilar from
the you know the tech suits and swimming
like it's getting weird yeah it's not
just steroids and EPO like now we're
entering into gene therapy and all kinds
of craziness where it's going to become
even you know it's gonna become a
hundredfold more difficult to try to
figure out what's fair and what's not
yeah I'm surprised no one has invented
shaving your head and swimming and then
covering like putting some sort of
silicone directly onto your scalp like
why hasn't that's gonna be them well the
caps are kind of like that yeah but
we've been shaving a little more time
off if it was probably directly adhered
to your skin all right now right like
some kind of lotion for years yeah or
something like that I don't know I did
want to bring up though before we get
off the doping in conversation or move
it in a different direction is that Nike
it is shocking to me and I don't know
what you think that it's company
like Nike that spend so much time on
branding initiatives that have to do
with the purity of the sport you know
they that I know of they have never
taken a stand on doping like they've
never launched a brand campaign about
clean sport and only using the body
you've got
am I wrong on that what do you make of
that well it's it is it would be
completely on brand for them if you're
looking at their brand Dec but when you
look at their marketing assets you know
you've got the NFL MLB you know they
would put themselves in a position to
look like the biggest hypocrites ever
because then they would have to take a
stand if something happens then it
everyone's gonna pull up that out
campaign well yeah I mean it's all of
its already happening I mean if you just
look at like if they really wanted to
stand for clean sport they could
completely change everything in a year
did they did do wasn't that Lance
Armstrong at you know what am I on I'm
on my bike that was a Nike Yard
that wasn't eight yet which is so - yeah
so maybe you know the the you know like
reflecting back on that it's like yeah
maybe we shouldn't do that like we're
still talking about that that's true but
like they for example if they decided
that a major brand value for them was
going to be clean sport they could
influence stricter rules in Major League
Baseball and the NFL around doping
offences rather than whatever they do a
couple games suspension or whatever it
is in some of these cases they could
influence I mean it can influence
everything they could they can move
mountains with the amount of money and
marketing dollars and that the level of
assets like top athletes in every sport
I just wonder what could they do if they
set their mind to it like yeah it would
be awkward and uncomfortable at first I
mean they could clean edges they could
create like a Manhattan Project around
it with the resources that they have but
you know clearly it's not part of their
business no and I think that you know
part of that is perhaps a function of
the fact that the way we perceive doping
in sports like track and field and
swimming and cycling is very different
from what it looks like in
the NFL in the NBA and major league
baseball like it it's almost like those
sports get a pass like we don't really
every once in a while there's the a-rod
kind of situation but I can't imagine
what's actually going on there that just
gets you know unnoticed so there is a
disparity in the way that we think about
[Music]
doping in sports in those various
disciplines there is and there the kind
of I guess that's what I mean by they're
sort of the common player in all of them
so if you were gonna make sweeping
change culturally I don't know who else
could do it they certainly have the
marketing muscle to be able to create
impact in anything that they decide to
focus yeah you know which kind of opens
up a new discussion right about how the
decision the way that they've kind of
decided to do that and and one of the
other things that's been a big kind of
deal in the running world in recent
memory is the way that that Nike has
dealt with maternity leave with their
pregnant female athletes and it was a
big story that like again back to
lindsay crouse like she's like
incredible like she's breaking all the
stories she's also an amazing runner
yeah she's getting ready for New York
right now like I just love reading
everything that she does and she broke
this story right yeah yeah and so this
is another thing that you've had a few
things to say about so maybe like just
explain this situation for people that
are listening who are unfamiliar yeah
well so with being a professional woman
runner you kind of view your motherhood
plan your parenting plan based on your
job I think that's probably true and
well beyond sport right but the way
contracts were set up there was no
mention of the word pregnancy
specifically but it was well known that
pregnancy was treated as a injury and
and I don't know about this across all
brands but I know that what well that's
great right right then my pregnancy is
an injury yeah like we're just on the
wrong path
totally and generally athletes would
some sort of a clause around if you
don't compete within this many days I
mean that could be as short as eight
weeks up to six months if you don't
compete within that number of days then
you could get a contract reduction of
50% or 35% or you could be dropped or if
you lose your world ranking or your
national ranking not to be written into
your contract if you lose that or it
drops below a certain amount you would
lose significant amount of pay so as a
younger woman looking at my contract it
it didn't look like baby's fit in there
anywhere and most of the conversations
that I'd have with my peers involved if
I want to have kids it's gonna be when I
retire because you know you're gonna
have to like move on and that's just
always what I thought I thought I went I
thought I'd race for about eight years
and then start a family and that'd be it
and and so it's just it's so it pushes
you into such a non creative space and
you learn you lose all this great talent
right when they're entering their prime
so what happened was
Alysia montaño helped bring the story
forward of what happened to her with
lindsay crouse in that story that I
wrote with news six-time Olympic yeah I
mean she's getting 11 time world
champion six time medallist she's won
like six medals but she's getting them
all ten years after the fact right from
like doping right back to the doping
that's that's kind of those rungs are
being righted the best they can so I
think she just got a medal at Doha World
Championships from like 2011 or
something we went to the same high
school ELISA and I are really oh you did
wow your friends I wasn't bridesmaid in
her wedding I mean we're tight and so I
couldn't think of a better face for that
movement than Alisha and just what she
went through but yeah he's the one that
tripped in the 800 yeah she was at the
trials and had like a big emotional
display understandably but yeah it was
that was horrible and heartbreaking so
that's kind of what happened she did
this beautiful video piece + op Edie
with lindsay crouse about her
experiences of essentially being let go
having
her contracts threatened with ASIC Sivan
and then really bring into the forefront
of people's attention like why should
this be so especially in the wake of
Nike having just produced this ad about
like women can do anything they can
dream of and featuring all these moms
and the ads and all the stuff so it
wouldn't be such a big deal in this
arena of course yeah and Serena this
huge story and so their marketing women
mothers with this lie essentially like
mother athletes doing these incredible
things with the support of Nike in these
very dramatic tear-jerking videos and
then here's the reality of what they do
to their female athletes behind closed
doors with their contracts with their
pay you know Carrie Goucher story was
very compelling because she was
suspended they didn't pay her for a year
when she was pregnant with Colt
but they required her to do all of these
appearances I can't remember the number
if it was like 11 or 16 appearances she
was on the cover of runner's world she
actually became more famous than ever
that year she wasn't getting paid at all
but she was working for them and she was
not allowed to seek payment from anyone
else any competitor it was exclusivity
yeah so I don't even think that's legal
that you could basically for ransom or
someone to work for free I've heard of
this before right well there's so many
interesting facets to this I mean when I
first kind of casually came across the
story my first instinct was well this
must be antiquated boilerplate language
that was inserted in these contracts
forever ago and nobody bothered to
really kind of update it but I was
resistant or reluctant to like infer
malevolence like I just thought well
this is just you know this is outdated
and they're just late fixing this but it
sounds like there's been women trying to
challenge this all along and and it's
not just Nike I mean Nikes at the
forefront of this but there are other
brands that are doing this as well but
and they've been like no this is this is
the line that we're drawing yes and and
and I think it's it speaks to a bigger
issue which you have like you're an
interesting figure in this and what I
want to say which is this whole industry
is built up
on this paradigm of athletic performance
like your value is directly Wed to
podiums appearances what races are you
gonna be on and what podiums are you
going to stand to top we're in a very
different world now and you're like the
first generation of people and a leading
voice in this movement which is that
these things need not be so directly
coupled like you have a voice and a
point of view and fanbase and you know
legions of very loyal people that care
very much what you have to say in my
opinion that transcends whatever podium
you like that's way more powerful for a
brand then oh you're gonna get a silver
or bronze it's some meat in Doha or
whatever that the general public doesn't
even really care about yeah but this is
the legacy of that right and I feel like
we're in this middle ground now where
these brands haven't really cottoned on
to the fact that the world has changed
absolutely and you know I'm always
uncomfortable with calling myself a
pioneer in something with this being one
not sure because you started well yeah
oh gee blogger yeah in 2009 when we
started having these tools available to
us I decided because I was sort of
disillusioned with my first six years as
a professional athlete I thought that if
I just became a national champion they
would use me in marketing and
advertising and I and we could help I
could be a person that helped bring the
sport to a greater audience and you know
and I won a national championship and
nothing happened
I did great job with interviews it
didn't matter
we couldn't seem to get anything outside
of our little circle of running media
and and I was like well that when social
media and blogging came to my attention
I'm like you can write your own story
you don't have to wait around for
non-endemic media to come knocking on
your door and decide your story's worth
while you make your story worthwhile you
tell your own story and the readers will
find you I mean it was so empowering and
so I I did I started doing that in 2009
and and so by the time 2012 camera
my contract was gonna be up with Nike I
this was my second conversation with the
CEO Mark Parker but in this one I came
into his office essentially to say hey I
want to have a baby this model that we
have that you just described so well
wretch of is antiquated why are we still
basing our contracts on this I have been
blogging I have been using social media
I have an audience I have a story that's
much richer than it's not dependent on
being on the podium but I'm trying to
refine my contract with Nike and they
have devalued me at 20 15 20 percent of
what I was paid before but I'm more
valuable than I've ever been and this is
crazy like basically telling him that
the person he had in charge of sports
marketing contracts was totally outdated
and that they were going to be missed
opportunities especially with women
because when at that moment I wanted to
have a child and was thinking this is
actually a story that applies and is you
know valuable to a lot of women and you
look at who's who's signing up for road
race is 65% women right that's that's
their customer base that's their
audience like what was Parker's response
it was like pretty lukewarm you know it
was it was shocking to me I know and
because life was a little record holder
in the 5k at one point I mean what is
what you know what is the annual revenue
of Nike numbers that are it's it's
numbers you can't even wrap your head
around and we're talking about you know
just my new dollars yeah allocate
towards this thing where if they'd
gotten out in front of it with the
pregnancy stuff or with people like
yourself like identifying like hey
Lauren has a voice like there's
something really interesting going on
here
let's put a little marketing muscle and
a few dollars behind this and the amount
of goodwill that they could engender
with their customer base would have the
ROI on that is insane so it just seems
completely myopic to me it is is crazy
and I do think that there was an element
of Mark Parker not wanting to step on
the toes of somebody that is in charge
of a department whose
in there for 25 years or whatever right
I'm sure that people don't want to get
up in someone's business unless they
really really want to go to bat for
something because I felt like the
conversation when we were eyeball to
eyeball in his office was one where he
was hearing me but I also didn't leave
feeling like he was gonna do anything
about it and that was really
discouraging and it was a the first time
I went in to mark Parker's office was in
2006 right after I had won my US
Championship and I had tried to work
with the global sports marketing
director trying to talk about how why
are the why is the Nike Women's Catalog
completely full of models but you're
using your top male athletes to model
the clothes for your sportswear company
why are wittmeyer models modeling the
women's stuff and athletes modeling you
know and he was like that's not my
department that's brand whatever
essentially like this isn't what I do
I sign athletes and they win medals
that's what I do and so I ended up
emailing mark Parker at 2:00 in the
morning by guessing his email address
based on the formula of everyone's email
address and he emailed me back and it
was Jesse who told me to do that my
husband because he was so sick of
watching me stew over it he's like just
email him like all right I'll try and
you did reply it and in that particular
instance when it that first time I went
into his office I was so nervous and but
I was heard and changes were made right
he got ahold of his head of brand and
you know things happened and things
changed and I felt it was really it was
probably the first time that I remember
getting over the anxiety around using my
voice using it and having something big
happen and so yeah so it was just so
different from the second time when I
came in there you know there's
everybody's got their line and moms
didn't make it motherhood didn't make it
at that time so I was really I was
really relieved when that story broke
with Elise Young lindsay crouse to see
that if i couldn't be the person that
made a difference somebody else could
make a difference yeah the video is
incredible yeah and she does that race
while she's pregnant
yeah in the video school we should say
like like we
focused a lot on Nike because you know
you were with Nike and and you know Nike
is obviously the biggest target but this
is like an industry yeah issue you could
tell it was industry-wide because in the
wake of the ad companies were coming out
one after the other with revised
language yeah
and Burton was one of the early ones
noon you know was all the reason I went
to was all and they find me pregnant I
don't know if that has ever happened
actually if a brand signed a
professional athlete while openly
pregnant with them yeah and you're a
partner in that company right yeah
that's already cool yeah it's very cool
well I feel like things are changing but
they're not changing quickly enough
that's always the case you know right
right I guess right we're in an era now
where we're celebrating like the
strength of women athletes in a way that
we haven't before and and we are seeing
this incredible resurgence in American
distance running women which is kind of
cool and credible but there are so many
things that's still need fixing yeah
there are no there are and I as a
retired professional you know athlete
I'm still really involved in the
community I try to keep my self engaged
on mostly issues of gender equality
racial equality ability anything like
that that any progress that can be made
and I just try to make sure that I'm up
to date the best that I can and helping
kind of disseminate information to the
audience the best I can
yeah in a very honest and authentic way
yeah you know like you don't you know
you you're not afraid to share your
opinion what is so awesome people cannot
follow the back to the murkiness for a
minute yeah the other big thing that's
kind of going on right now especially as
we go into Olympic year is is the role
of intersex athletes in female sports
which is so you've spoken about pretty
frequently so where are we at right now
in terms of what's legal and what's not
and that whole
confusing landscape yeah well I don't
actually know every time you know it's
new stuffs coming on seems to be
changing a lot in the World
Championships caster Semenya wasn't
competing in the women's eight and the
the ruling around essentially built
around her but athletes that share a
similar biology of being it's DSD
differences in sexual development
intersex is another way of putting it
but differences of sexual development is
kind of like the broader terminology so
yeah ground athletes that are born with
differences in that way and and so you
know that seems like it's fight it's
being fought in court it's switching
directions all the time she won an
appeal and then the rower came back down
and I don't know I mean I feel like I've
spoken about it a lot but I actually
haven't taken a strong stance because I
feel like I still need more information
it's so complicated i 100% feel that
every human being should have the
benefits of sport in their life if they
want them I mean the benefits of sport
are too great I don't want to put a wall
between someone and and sports just
because of differences of sexual
development or differences of gender
identity or anything and so I'm really
uncomfortable with any wall or barrier
put up for someone based on that but
participation in this is one thing for
being a professional at something is
another thing and so I don't know you
know I just don't know I know what it
feels like to compete against the best
in the world and compete against someone
who I feel has an unfair advantage if
you have a difference of sexual
development that has led you to go
through male pattern puberty from you
know act testes that are functional and
you you can actually use the androgens
like because you could have internal
testes but not be able to be insensitive
to the androgens which means you don't
get the external changes in your body
but if you are sensitive to the
androgens and you do undergo a male
pattern a traditionally male pattern of
puberty you know you you have
a different advantage you just do and so
but then what do you do with that
information do you just say that's just
the way it is maybe I don't know yet the
more the more that I've read up on this
the more confused I get yeah and the
more uncertain I am about my kind of
knee-jerk reactions yeah because on the
one hand you look at caster and this is
not to be clear we're not talking about
transgendered athletes we're talking
about people that are born a certain way
so I think casters medical records are
sealed so we don't know for sure but
everyone is fairly certain and in
suspecting that she's XY right that she
has that she she it certainly exudes
these intersex qualities should she be
punished for that because that's the
wage that she was born it's certainly
not her fault
no it's certainly the same way that
Michael Phelps has gigantic feet or
whatever it's like this is this is what
sport is so we can't like relegate her
to the sidelines it's to no fault no I
mean the only difference is that sport
it is divided into two categories
no one female and it's not like this
person is divided by foot size you know
I know it's it's so excited so there was
there was a ruling that that if you
reduce that person's testosterone levels
then you create a more equitable field
of play but then was that overruled like
I haven't been keeping track oh yeah
it's that I think that what my
understanding was that that ruling is
was put back in place for the World
Championships because I don't know why
else caster wouldn't have been able to
appeal that but then you know there's I
forget her name dr. Kristina's cars US
or something she she's written a book on
testosterone and really downplaying
testosterone as this critical you know
variable that it is the one yeah yeah
exactly we can't put yeah everything in
to know that and like you said like some
people like the amount of testosterone
doesn't necessarily indicate
the level that the impact that it's
having in that that varies from physique
to physique it does and so it's but as
someone who studied human biology at
Stanford yeah there you go hey it's you
know there is a difference in puberty of
what happens with testosterone and a
combination of other hormones has an
effect on the physique of the body so
and the size of the lungs and all these
other things so it's like I don't know
that the person in me that sort of tries
to pull my competitive side out that's
like okay pretend you were never an
elite athlete pretend you're just a
person who believes in human rights and
that's the most important thing that
version of me wants to say a person
should just be able to compete however
they want to compete all types of women
even if that's complicated but then that
would include people who identify as
female who were born male as well I mean
I raised in a half-marathon in Eugene
and there was a person who was
transgender female who was competing and
I was passing her and I remember
thinking I wonder the competitive
athlete me was like I wonder which
category this person's entered in I
wonder if I just passed someone in you
know I was trying to move up through the
women women ranks not as a professional
anymore but just because I'm competitive
and then I was like why does it matter
at this level that I'm at now I'm not
trying you know I'm not fighting over
limited resources limited metals doesn't
matter what category this person's in
I'm just stoked that they're out here
having an amazing time and sport but I
had that wrestling inside still yeah you
know so it's interesting being on the
non elite athlete side now kind of
seeing where you sit with it so I don't
know well I think when you're you know
post retirement it's not a zero-sum game
anymore but when you are competing at
the highest level it is a it is a
function of limited resources there's
only one gold medal there's only so many
spots that that you know that that are
going to comprise that Olympic team and
everybody's vying for that and so these
things become very acute they do and it
sort of makes me
think one solution which nobody's
proposing is to change some of that
zero-sum culture of the sport why does
it have to be that only metals are the
one the only people who in metals can
actually make a living why is it that a
fleets go to the Olympics and don't get
paid at all for going there well the IOC
makes billions of dollars like if you
changed it where anyone who made the
team is gonna make money and they're
going to be successful which is a lot of
how Road races work you get an
appearance fee that's so big it doesn't
actually matter that much if you win a
prize so if you just get paid for being
a professional then your tension around
someone who was born with different
internal genitalia than you being in the
same race as you it's not such a big
deal really
right because you're still gonna be able
to pay your bills you're gonna be I'll
pay your bills yeah and so it's just
like anything else you know you deprive
people to the point where they're at
each other instead of trying to be at
you the person who makes the system yeah
and I think it's exacerbated in sports
like track and field and and and
swimming where there are a couple few at
the very top who are doing very well and
then there's all the journeyman people
who are incredible athletes and are
literally scraping by just to make a
living I was talking to a friend of mine
just the other day multiple gold
medalist in swimming who's who's going
for it again and it's like it is this
this person can't get sponsors they're
like trying to figure out how they're
gonna like you know make a you know just
basically like feed themselves to get to
the Olympic Games is what well they must
celebrate it out yes haven't like I just
was thinking this is insane totally the
case totally insane and then we have you
know gavin newsom who's it trying to
initiate these changes in the in situ a
to allow amateur athletes to to prop I
mean I think these things are you know
overdue they are way overdue it's insane
that we have that the Olympic sports mod
model depends on free labor on a
continually like re surfacing group or
not resurfacing regenerative group right
it's always new people there's never
gonna be a shortage of talent they're
gonna keep coming up and they'll do it
for free I mean that's that's the model
of this Olympics it's like
it's predatory imagine imagine if if
basketball or football was like that if
we're they're like oh no you just you
just work for free all year every year
if you win the Super Bowl though you'll
get some money good luck making it to
the Super Bowl without any money and
it's getting even more complicated now
with social media because people have
realized you know young athletes have
realized that that you know they are you
know I hate this word but their quote
unquote brands and yeah they develop
audiences young through their various
channels and when they're in college
should they be allowed to make money on
their Instagram account or not like is
that a violation of NCAA rules like what
does it mean to be an amateur athlete
anymore and should that just go the way
of the dodo altogether
Wow just make a living however they
choose to I think so absolutely you know
I'm not a against some sort of go ahead
and make your living and pay some sort
of a tax on that that subsidizes all
varsity sports for example like if
you're gonna be making money like yes
the athletes are bringing in revenue for
football and basketball at the college
level
but also these other athletes that are
building their brands they rely on that
system to have regular competitions for
them to keep their brand up and I think
that there's this tension that all these
smaller sports will disappear if we
start letting tops athletes get paid you
know and it cuts into the n-c-double-a
revenue and they won't be able all these
other sports will get cut although you
know whatever your own Grammys I figure
out a way for where it's being shared
both ways yeah yeah in the same way that
you know a college if they're selling a
jersey with the name of a student
athlete on the back of it it's insane to
me that the athlete doesn't get to
participate and if there's an athlete
who's got millions of Instagram
followers and is monetizing that then
maybe some of that goes to the
university or the athletic department or
something at their school or something
like that I mean I think that's
reasonable but it seems just totally
dumb to me that you shouldn't be able to
make money on your Instagram account as
an athlete but your roommate who's not
an ass
post pictures and I'm like yeah you know
what I mean like Bobby Brown makeup here
we go and they're getting paid and
you're like this is so dumb it is it is
but it's it's amazing that it takes so
long for these things to catch up yeah
you know we have to have endless debate
and dialogue and then 10 years goes by
yeah and a generation of athletes who
could have you know navigated their
careers in a more functional healthy way
are sort of you know dispensed with yeah
solved this problem fair labor practices
I mean it just makes me think this is
just one anytime I talk about sports
whether it's with pregnancy or labor
practices its sports as the is one of
the things that people love to talk
about but it's just one of many many
many many many industries where unfair
labor practices exist where
discrimination against pregnancy
pregnant women or nursing women exists
you know it's it's endemic so but but
where I am okay talking about sports is
that if it's on everybody's mind and we
can make changes in sports you know yes
this is a privileged group that can kind
of make changes first sometimes but if
we can do that and then that doesn't
that's not a conversation ender but a
conversation starter and if athletes who
make these victories then go to bat for
everybody else then I'm cool with it I'm
not cool with just stopping at sports
though I feel like that's problematic to
me well it seems like that's what you
guys are doing it was L yeah so talk a
little bit about that and what sally has
created with this company it's pretty
cool he got to talk to Sally she is way
cooler than me but yeah all around
Twitter a better father for a long time
yeah she's amazing
um she's kind of an unlikely hero you
know she was like smoker and you hear
some caught some common hissing coughing
kind of background stuff I think a
little bit but sports saved her life and
she had this mixture of a passion for
design and like creativity and then this
passion for running because running
saved her life and so she was always
really the combination of those two
things and I was really attracted to was
all because they were speaking to the
woman athlete only whereas when I was at
Nike
I remember we made this groundbreaking
campaign called objectify me
and it was about making women's specific
shoe they kind of led the industry and
making the first woman's specific shoe
but even then as proud as I am of that
campaign the entire thing is in
reference to men men are still in the
campaign autumn existence is in
reference to men that campaign was a
reaction to your conversation with
Parker yeah it was and and but I didn't
even think about that until later when I
joined was L it's only women it's only
women's stuff it's only women in the
office
none of our stories are in reference to
male athletes we're not like the female
version of the men's this like it's just
women runners and and that is a big
enough group right and all the diversity
within that group so it's it's very
refreshing it's really cool and I really
kind of grew into myself as a woman
through my relationship with wazzle
obviously I was starting to find a
feminist streak to be attracted to them
but it was really the conversations I
was trying to have at Nike around
motherhood around trying to recognize
that this new model of marketing had
emerged and that the audience didn't
care about performance only they cared
about the whole person and in particular
the whole woman in my case and the fact
that I couldn't get anywhere with that
there meanwhile I have one conversation
with Sally Bergesen CEO and founder of
was all and she's like what yeah
obviously
uh I don't actually care if you win
anything you mean I don't have to push
this boulder up a mountain and have it
roll on me every day she's like if you
like pushing the boulder up the mountain
every day great tell that story well
please that'd be great and she's like
really though we want you to be you and
and we want you to be you shine brightly
because when you do that it gives other
women the the feeling that they can do
that too and not be sort of limited into
whatever box it is which for me was a
performance box in my industry but every
woman and person has their box they're
being pushed into all the time about how
to define themselves versus being self
approved so yeah my my work with wazzle
I'm just extremely proud of what we do
they're the team that we've built that
different ways we've kind of made
changes in the industry but we're small
and so a lot of those things aren't
gonna be probably noticed on a global
stage until much later but I think that
20 years from now and people are talking
about big changes in sport behind every
one of those
big changes of women was all has had an
instrumental role whether it was
needling Nike or needling the press
engaging in conversations that helped
ship shift public opinion about things
and really doing it in that strong voice
that you just described me as having I
mean that's the voice Sally brings and
they encourage their athletes to bring
and I mean that is so different from
most companies where they want you to be
the superhero I remember it being a
pretty radical thing we assigned with
them yeah I mean they joked at the time
that they made as much money in a year
the revenue was the same size as left
gloves sold at Nike yeah and I mean
that's probably was still too small of a
number to be honest but we're people
telling you like this is the wrong move
you're gonna you're gonna destroy your
career doing this
I honestly think people just thought of
speaking a foreign language no one told
me don't do that it was more like what
you don't ya just puzzlement like who's
Louise le right who is what I wasn't
there a weird thing where there was some
meet maybe it was trials where the bibs
had to have like a Nike logo on them or
you couldn't like there was some
confusion about like leading sponsors
for an event coming into conflict with
the brands that the athletes were allied
with that was L found itself in the
crosshairs with I just remember reading
something about yeah well I think maybe
there's been a few things that have
happened but the story that came to mind
from you is when they sponsored their
first professional athletes it was for
the 2012 Olympic Trials and they were
just trying their this small tiny little
company you know two years old or
something at a time or four years old at
the time they're trying to make their
first elite kit for the US Olympic
Trials stage and they have to submit it
for review and it was like well no you
can't do that no you can't do that no
you can't do that no you can't do that
and they're like well they're like make
it smaller make it less legible make it
that you know and she was like well can
we put this bird pattern on it no too
many birds no birds allowed you know
like just like and so they ended up with
the most blase Jersey ever and I'm sure
they wouldn't mind me saying that
because it's true it was just this kind
of what was supposed to be an exciting
launch of a new play or a woman's focus
player onto the national stage of a
sport you're like you're like happy
anybody new is putting money in track
and field at this point and the sort of
welcome they received was it's just it
just showed why nobody wants to enter
the sport yeah it was just like wow
but they've persisted you know mostly
because I don't know how much longer
they're gonna be able to do it but man
it's a track and field needs them in
there it's that thing where you want to
widen the aperture to bring new people
in and to create interest and yet when
you make those moves you could shut down
it's the same I think that's there's
there's an aspect of that with chogi
1:59 thing too where it's like yeah we
want more people to be interested in
track and field but it has to be on our
terms
yep it can't be in this other way that
actually people are interested only know
that's for sure true yeah I know Sally's
great though and the work that we're
gonna do I think over the next few years
will be will continue to push those
conversations for you know we've got
Olympic Trials next year 2020 we're
hosting the World Championships in
Eugene Oregon first World Championships
for track and field in the US I mean big
deal yeah lots to look forward to well
let's let's track your story a little
bit
you grew up you grew up not too far from
here yeah yeah kick-ass high school
state champion runner I'm sure you're
recruited everywhere right but you end
up going to Stanford and not on a
scholarship yeah okay no question of a
lifetime well I did the same thing you
did yeah well I wasn't as good as you I
was a walk-on I didn't deserve it I
didn't deserve a scholarship well I was
a little bit of a I guess a late bloomer
in a way I don't know sort of under the
radar I was 14 that the footlocker
Championships as a junior in junior year
is the most important year for
recruiting so I got a lot of letters
from smaller schools and medium schools
but as far as that top top-10 cross
country programs in the nation I reached
out to most of them
a second at footlocker my senior year so
I was right up in there and I won all my
state titles senior year you know so a
lot of the money had been given away at
these top cross country schools to
people who are stars as juniors and I
didn't have the home advantage of
growing up in a household where college
was normal my my mom and dad didn't go
to college out of high school my mom got
her associate's degree the same year I
graduated high school actually she went
back to school for an associate's degree
in business and so none of them really
knew the landscape and so I didn't know
I was way behind when I was writing
these letters to the schools like I
didn't even know what early applications
where I'm not even using the right
terminology because I still they don't
know what it is but um so I I wanted to
look at the big ones at that time were
Arizona northern Arizona UCLA which was
right down the street
Stanford and Colorado that was are my
top five and the ones I wanted to take
recruiting trips to and I mean UCLA
never wrote me a single letter that was
the weirdest one my high school coach
Dave DeLong of Canyon high bless him he
called the coach there at the time and
was just like what are you doing man she
lives right down the street she just
made her second at the locker are you
not interested and but in the end I
didn't want to be that close to home I
wanted to have a little bit of an
adventure
yeah so you walk on and then you end up
having this incredible career yeah
winning all contents to a titles like
some crazy number of all-american like
15 15 oh yeah across cross country and
track and field
yeah and in so doing like from what I
gather at the time the men's program was
a very congealed like well they called
it the Machine yeah still is I think and
you were starting to notice like why
isn't the women's program kind of
operating with this same perspective and
philosophy and you worked hard to try to
cultivate that and create that in your
own way mm-hmm I did and it was it was
really difficult yeah I really envied
the environment of the Machine on the
men's side but since then
I'm coach and now that I have more
perspective on kind of how a misogyny
and sexism works I have a different view
of what was going on there and it still
goes on today all across country might
even still be going on there I don't
know but a lot of times which you have
as a men's head coach it's like 90
something percent of the coaches at that
time or men don't know what it is now
but still really really high and their
head men's and women's coach and they
hire an assistant that generally works
with the women's team and that head
coach kind of dances in and out of their
involvement with the women's team oh so
there isn't a separate head women's
coach a lot of times know we had an
assistant women's coach when I was there
and that persisted you know even just
talking to Rebecca O'Meara who is an
athlete I coach now who graduated there
there was a there was often a similar
dynamic going on of that head coach of
both programs but really the women's
team was second priority and they often
trusted a assistant oftentimes a woman
assistant which is a amazing gesture but
then when you really look at how that
works career-wise that person is doing
crazy amounts of work and making pennies
for it and they don't actually have full
power they still have to kind of check
in with the head coach all the time and
so when you're an athlete interacting
with a coach in that way so I should
school like Stanford where these
athletes were at best in the nation you
know top top top recruits we got that we
were ranked number one every single year
I was there but we never finished first
and but you had this feeling that you
weren't important and you weren't really
getting what you deserved
and so many times you'd ask your
assistant coach or something and they'd
have to go check with the head coach it
was just really weird but when I was at
Stanford I went into Vin's office when I
saw this dynamic and I was like this
isn't gonna work for me I need you to
coach me you know and he did he ended up
being kind of my direct coach but he
really only worked with I don't even
know one I might've been the only woman
he worked with regularly well one of the
things you've written about it speaks to
a larger issue which is which is across
all sport men versus women in that you
have these young men they're coming into
their
you know full-blown testosterone-fueled
bodies yeah natural
performance-enhancing drug grabbing it
kind of lends itself to creating that
cohesiveness and a team yeah constructs
yeah you know I experienced that as an
athlete at Stanford and and conversely
what you have with women are bodies that
are changing you're having you know
interesting things that are happening
physiologically that are very different
from that that tend to push women apart
from each other well and then create
that cohesion yeah you're right you have
biology is playing a completely
different role you're either going to be
if you're lucky a plateau for a little
while but most women experience some
sort of performance dip and then you so
that's that's massively at play then you
add in kind of inherited gender weird
[ __ ] where's socially women are taught
to view each other as competitors for it
limited prizes and I know men have their
own version of that but for women
there's the tendency to tear one another
down I think that a lot of that is
changing or maybe it's just in my world
I don't feel that it at all anymore
anywhere I go but I definitely felt that
when I was younger you you were careful
to make a woman you're to really trust
another woman who was a competitor for
something and then you had those team
dynamics like I just said of like you
get less of the attention of the most
powerful person you're fighting for that
limited resources fuels that scarcity
mindset yeah and so you have all these
different things making it difficult to
be a cohesive unit
to kind of expect what you can achieve
and so you get this ranking a national
ranking based on prepubescent bodies and
then half of your team is going through
like a pretty significant weight
fluctuation and performance fluctuation
that's just natural that can be ridden
out and overcome through time but that's
that also is something that I I really
am passionate about is is treating
women's running culture as its own
entity to be respected and normalized
instead of comparing it to men so part
of the normal expected trajectory of
women
is a plateau or a dip that's normal and
it doesn't need to be bad it can be
celebrated if it's part if it's part of
the expectation and so we have to find
ways to build team culture around that
we need coaches to be educated around
that there has to be a little bit of a
broadening of an athletes value during
that period of time when their
performance or is dipping you know so
there has to be baked into the culture
of the team you may need to develop the
pride of being the fifth scorer on your
cross country team when you're used to
being the one breaking the tape right
and that's a transition that is
difficult do you feel like that's
getting noticed and appropriately kind
of acknowledged because I feel like the
typical scenario and like I'm an old man
so I don't know what's really going on
now but but you have coaches saying
you're too heavy you got to lose weight
yeah and and these transitionary phases
just foment you know disordered eating
habits and body just you know sort of
you know body issues and all the life
yeah you know it's a big thing of what
you're constantly yeah that's still the
biggest problem is that these women's
changes in their bodies are met with
exactly the opposite of what they need
they're met with if you're a dedicated
athlete you'll lose you'll lose this
weight and it's like wait a second what
if what your body needs is to actually
go through this period of change and
then it will even itself out that if you
look at the athletes who have had
longevity the female athletes have a
longevity and you look back at their
college pictures before they became pros
they all went through these body changes
and weathered them but you have a coach
who's like his his his horizon is just
NC to a champion yes in four months or
whatever you know so he's not thinking
about the five-year career plan totally
because what's incentivized for the
coaches is where is this all baked in
right look at the system are they
incentivized only based on their podium
finishes or could we incentivize them by
how many women continue running after
college maybe you need a different
metric of success when you are in charge
of a group of women going through this
particular phase of life than just make
them deliver top-notch n-c-double-a
performances and I know that's asking a
lot and it sounds crazy
but a lot of these coaches jobs aren't
as at-risk as you'd think they're in
there for a long time and I have seen
some changes women women at or men
coaches getting let go and pushed out
for creating negative body image culture
I get people come up to me all the time
because of the letter I wrote to my
younger self through mile split that was
all printed 500 copies of and personally
mailed to coaches around the country Wow
yeah and that's the kind of stuff they
do that's like way different
non-traditional marketing dollars spent
and yeah and and it is making a
difference I have coaches and particular
makes me happy when I have male and
female coaches working with high school
kids they're like I give your letter to
your younger self to my team every year
or whatever it is and then I know that
in some way they their perception on
body changing body changes has changed I
don't know if I'm influencing the
college level it's hard to know they're
kind of insular so I love that letter
that you read it again this morning
yeah I'll link it up in the show now
it's talk a little bit about what
inspired that yeah well I mean the mile
split team asked me if I'd write a
letter to my younger self because they
are doing a series from professional
athletes and I jumped on it because I
had been really immersing myself in
Eating Disorder culture and body image
negative body image culture and the
toxic effect it was having on women's
teams and when individual women and I
thought this is an area where I can I
can make a difference because I've been
steeped in it so much in trying to learn
and understand it and so yeah dr. melody
Moore she's a clinical psychologist who
specializes in eating disorder recovery
she actually lives around this area she
was a big influence on helping me
understand the clinical side because I
had sort of the performance side and my
own lens on it and I had a good
understanding of the challenges baked
into the culture the specific culture of
high performance sport and she had the
broader lens of how the disease works
and the the beauty myth that's that
women are facing on the whole so yeah I
just tried to pull all that together in
this letter to my younger self to in a
way that would translate it the most
direct way I could to like the
mine's you know so I don't know it's I'm
proud of it it seems like it's worked
better than I could have hoped but it's
still it's still relevant and still gets
shared and spread around yeah you know
needs to be better when did you write it
it was a few years ago a couple years
ago yeah I think that what my dream at
the time and kids have made this
challenging they've really made it
challenging to kind of do all the things
I really want to do as anyone kids know
but I have I had this vision of
following up that letter to my younger
self with proposed changes at the unci
double-a level and the national high
school level of kind of like a suggested
curriculum for coaches for how to better
understand the role they play in
creating eating disorder culture and
negative body image culture and really
bringing a gravity to them to understand
the role that they play for better or
for worse and to kind of help them
develop some best practices I really
wanted to do that and I haven't I went
so far I did this survey I'd like almost
800 participants talking about their
experiences of body image culture it's
just it's so much work you know it's
just so much that's a worthy investment
of your time it would be yeah it would
be but how do you know well listen
you're excelling in so many categories
you're an incredibly capable human being
I mean like in addition to being like
the elite of the elite at running your
this crazy entrepreneur you're
unbelievable writer like I've written
down here like when is this memoir
coming out like I mean I've been
following your writing for a very long
time and and just thought years ago you
would have come out with a book you know
like I know you have your journals and
all they're amazing and all of that but
like a book book yeah this is at least
one you have to do and you know like I
texted Jesse last night I was like
Lawrence coming in like what's not
obvious that I can talk to her about
that I'm not gonna find out Google
already and he's like she's a musician
she's write songs and like that's a sing
I was like on top of everything else
you're like a musician too I have a
guitar back Oh
you know parents like all the things
that you do and and the fact that you're
at all beating yourself up because
there's something else that you you have
an ambition around that you don't have
time for I mean yes the human condition
it is I've never had a shortage of ideas
but I'm not the best at executing them
without like a good team or at least a
good partner you know and a lot of the
work that I've been able to do in the
last couple of years has been because
I've had the team of was all behind me
that is essentially cheering me on every
step of the way I mean like how can we
help how can we elevate what you're
trying to do and that's massively
encouraging it can take something from
the idea to action right and I wasn't
gonna print 500 letters to my younger
self and research all the addresses and
of every high school that I could think
of and you know I wasn't gonna be able
to do that but they could say hey this
is important to you this is important to
women's running we're gonna do it and
then the same with the believe journal
my my former competitor and dear friend
Roma Cadogan from Ireland because of her
it went from an idea to actually
happening you know she was married to a
graphic designer
and she was able to help make this
imaginary book come to life on a
computer which could then be printed you
know it's just it would I gotta run
every year right like doing your update
yeah we update it and we refresh it and
stuff like that we haven't done a big
overhaul in a couple years but we're
gonna do a big overhaul to the content
for the next one right yeah but the book
is the thing I really want to do and
that's you got to do that I want to do
that I need to do it you know when you
when you are going crazy on the days you
aren't writing you know you need to
write mm-hmm it's a it's a very
aggravated story I know a guy who's a
big-time writer director in Hollywood
like big big time and he's got a bunch
of kids and he's like everyone each one
of my kids cost me like three movies
yeah again that's the reality that no
one wants to talk about in you know you
know hustle culture it's like you can do
it all and it's like you're somebody
who's doing a lot but you still can't do
everything
and be a present partner and parent and
you know keep all these super important
things in check yeah I mean you're the
way I try to think of it now is there's
all these things not being made but I'm
making something that can't be marketed
or sold but I don't even understand yet
when it comes to my marriage and my kids
right and so that's at least that's the
lullaby I sing to myself at night when
I'm feeling anxious and I want to write
at my computer until 2:00 in the morning
but that would be a bad move soon CD
gets up at 6:00 like you know what
you're making something you're making
something else there yeah
it's not wasted time but yeah it's tough
it's tough I really struggle yeah I
struggle with motherhood for sure your
struggles are you know well-documented
in terms of your athletic career as well
yes this is you know your I think
Lindsey Lindsey in that beautiful New
York Times that the sort of elegy that
she wrote to you on your retirement was
like you know Lauren is is the best
American distance runner to never make
an Olympic team it seemed like every
time there was an Olympiad something
interfere to prevent you from realizing
that dream and I just wonder like what
your perspective is on all of that now
looking back thinking like what could
have been what is being in acceptance
and and you know moving forward I mean
you have an incredible life so it's not
like there's nothing to lament but I
would imagine there are still you know
you still have this sense of like it was
supposed to be this way yeah in another
way for sure and I often think about how
much easier certain things would be if I
had the title of Olympian if just one of
those years had gone slightly
differently you know the hardest of
those years being 2008 I was an
alternate for the team up until the last
minute I didn't know if because there
were a couple athletes doubling 10k 5k
and I was in the 5k and so I didn't know
up until last minute if somebody would
decide not to come back in the 5k and so
I just stayed on guard and I trained all
the way up to that Olympics I was like
the ghost Olympian back home that never
was and and I was really sort of in
denial about it until it's like the last
possible moment I could be called and I
always was aware that while the Olympics
was an odd
Skol society feeds you right it's the
most obvious goal that it wasn't the
only thing to make it work that I just
knew it would make things easier it
would open doors so I wanted it yeah
well on it I wanted it out of pride
because I because I could have earned it
but then yeah and so I think about that
sometimes with like even this book I'm
working on how do I write the book
proposal do I write it as the fastest
runner to never make the Olympics tells
her story of whatever but it's just part
of my story and I think that when you
what I have seen is that when you
accomplish one of those things that is
so easily identified as quote success
Olympic medal whatever I think it is I
think it would be harder in some ways to
be self approved you know like I feel
like I was sort of forced into finding
self approval in my career because I
didn't get what I wanted I didn't get
that ultimate prize I can't go by the
title Olympian I don't have people going
around telling me I accomplished
everything in the sport that I set out
to do so it's like well I got to find
the piece there I got to find peace with
that and and that's the theme of life
anyway everyone has to find eventually
it so not getting what I want pushed me
there sooner well when you get what you
want it's harder to you know reckon with
yourself in an honest way yeah got
yourself a bunch of [ __ ] yeah and
everyone Pat's you on the back yep when
it doesn't go your way then you really
have to kind of get on us yeah yeah I
think that when I got what I wanted
until I didn't but when I got what I
wanted there was apartment was felt I
deserved it and then when I didn't get
what I wanted I was like but I deserve
it and then it kind of clicked like oh
there's people everywhere that deserve
something and don't get it I never
deserved any of it no one deserves
anything really you know so I don't know
I think I would like to think I'm a
better person because I didn't get what
I want but I don't really know do you do
you spend a lot of mental energy
thinking about it or of you is that just
in the past now I mean because you're a
coach and you're still very much in the
sport it's not like you've just put
that's in the rearview and now you have
this whole other life
yeah I have a conflicted feeling about
staying in the sport actually for that
reason there was when I was thinking
about retiring a big part of me wanted
to just close the door and leave it
behind and I've seen a lot of my peers
do that and it's very tempting because
it eats at you there's part like the
more you stay in the sport that the
doping stuff keeps eating at you my
seventh in the world finish with all
these suspicious people and how many how
many people have you raised that have
beaten you who have been toppled by
doping or are under the you know dark
suspicion yeah behavior and they kind of
I don't think I'll ever I'll ever really
know so it's just it would there's a big
part of me that's like I would I would
be happy shutting the door diving into
music and writing never writing really
about sport but then because I do love
the coaching and I do really love my
relationship with Rozelle and this kind
of broader women's athlete movement I
get to be involved in sport in a way
that is very holistic where I'm
constantly learning and it it does mean
that I am kind of always getting pinged
by my past still because I am engaged
and it's just over there but it also
gives me the opportunity to continue
rewriting that story in my mind I mean
like actually that was really good
what I did was really good and actually
with a few more years under my belt you
know didn't really matter that much but
I didn't make the Olympics or I think I
think with every successive year it
becomes less important yeah and your
voice is as strong as ever and the
influence that you wield over your sport
and just the conversation that swirls
around female empowerment both in sport
and outside of sport you know continues
to build and grow yeah and it will
continue to build and grow and we need
voices who have an expertise in
performance in that conference almost
it's almost better because well here's
the thing like because if you like if
you just want every race you were in you
become very unreliable that's true and
your your whole thing is being playable
and be honest and like here's though you
know here's that here's what it looks
like warts and all yeah but the minute
you dawn a gold medal then it's like oh
well it's easy for her to say yeah I
mean but the fact that you didn't get
what you wanted
and you know there is an argument that
you know should have code of what a kind
of thing it makes you kind of more
endearing I think that that that that
helps you connect with the people that
are interested in what you have to say I
feel that and I think it gives me a
little bit of a of a I was gonna say
chip on my shoulder but it's not even
that with my coaching because I feel
like I have a very specific coaching
philosophy with the elite athletes I
coach which is I will train them to be
among the best in the world but not at
the expense of their personhood and I
had to sort of fight to regain it Rick
reclaim the importance of my personhood
during my career I had a few years where
I thought it was it was like a liability
and that I should just be this like you
know drone monk Runner person and that
that was the best way to go so I was
shutting out any other part of me the
musical part any any other part of me
really and I was like no I'm I want to
be a whole person and I ended up having
good results doing that against a better
judgement of the quote experts in my
field so I coach with like a fervor
around that now like who are you let's
not lose who you are let's chase this
thing yeah you need to make choices
you can't like do everything all the
time but you shouldn't lose track with
who you are because you're you you can
only be you as an athlete don't try to
be her don't try to be whatever and so
it means that I really need to get to
know who they are as people in order to
do that and I feel like I have something
to prove there - I want my success to be
measured by how many of those people of
these women leave the sport without an
identity crisis without going through a
sinking depression due to the like
impossibility of transitioning back into
a human self right and our is it
possible to get great results that way
we're finding out you're getting pretty
good ones how's it going great yeah how
many athletes do you have now we have
six on the team I coach five yeah so
it's but it's really and we have it a
pretty magical environment and actually
crosses outside of track and field which
is really exciting because we've got
Lindsey Corbin and Heather Jackson of
the
Kru I don't coach them I do some like
kind of advising with Heather but on the
running side but they come and work out
with us like are our gates are open to
come bring in that champion culture for
one another and Bend cuz they live in
Bend right and that's just so excited to
me so it's like being able to do that
into in town is like it's pretty good in
this tiny little idyllic little Whoville
were you yeah I'm watching them compete
at Kona was Lindsay did she got yeah
she's yeah yeah she seems really cool
I've never better but she seems awesome
she isn't and she wanted she won
Wisconsin I think right yeah I think so
yeah yeah I mean Heather got this and
had a you know great a great day I think
she's finished as high as third before
but she's also had some significantly
worse than fifth so it's good to see her
have a good one that's cool and how did
how did Jesse fare not being in Kona
yeah it was pretty it was pretty tough I
think you know it kind of came up on him
quickly right at the last minute because
he's so invested in picki bars and his
work and the family that he I don't feel
like he dwells on it every day but yeah
I start yet closer and the media buzz is
building and he's like I kind of wish I
was there even just socially to connect
with people I think he's starting to
feel pretty like it's moving in the rear
view mirror and I think that's tough
mm-hmm well there's similarities between
the two of your stories like it's
dealing with these injuries and you know
is is facing you know what's next for
him what is this relationship with
professional sports look like and and I
think that's a kid that's a tough
confusing emotional place to be
it is also raising kids in transformers
company and do all the other things I at
Jesse's story as an example of how
masculinity is packaged and sold in
sport being archaic we're like kind of
where where I was in 2012 sitting in the
room with Mark Parker at Nike trying to
talk about the value of the complete
person Jesse is this guy
who is a CEO picky Bars he's an
incredible dad he is very passionate
about equally shared parenting you know
really sharing the emotional labor of
home life which is very against
traditional ideas of masculinity right
and these are things that are on the
forefront of conversations around
redefining masculinity in our culture
right now to kind of help with some of
the major problems for face saying as a
society right around violence violence
against women to terrorism all these
things that are generally perpetuated
among men and the the unique ills that
men's men face the that you know the
article in The New York Times I think I
read recently was about the the average
man having a difficult time having these
emotional intimacy and their friendships
right because of these antiquated views
of masculinity and Jesse it's just such
an awesome example of being kind of on
the forefront of really doing it
differently but it and so at a point in
his career he's experienced all this
friction like it's all gonna need to be
behind him because of work and family
I'm like why isn't it that's just the
beginning in some ways for your for your
career as a professional athlete like
you can look different it doesn't have
to do the same like you couldn't do it
the way you could before but why is it
considered less valuable necessarily if
you want to do it differently well I
think I mean I would agree with
everything that you just said and echo
all of that but I think what happens is
all of that sort of progressive
Sensibility butts up against a
traditional idea of what it is to be a
man that like we still can't quite
escape which is I need to be this
champion and I need to be this
breadwinner and this is what it means to
be masculine and when you don't achieve
those goals or ambitions for yourself
there's a sense of emasculation that's a
place that makes you feel less than or
less than a man or like this is what I'm
this is where I'm supposed to be yes
point in my life and I'm not and I feel
like there's a there's a weird kind of
not shame but like you know a sense of
insecurity I think
goes hand-in-hand with that yeah what do
you think can be done about it I don't
know I mean I'm I'm far far be it for me
to give anybody advice I can only share
my own personal experience but I I've
gone through this and I remember as I
was trying to figure out who I wanted to
be as I was transitioning out of law it
was a very confusing time and it was
also very there was a lot of financial
hardship and I have vivid memories of
being down at the park in Malibu with my
two daughters like pushing them on the
swings and it was like 2 o'clock on a
Tuesday and it's a bunch of moms yeah
and I'm down there and I and and I had
these conflicting emotions of like how
cool is it that I can be in the middle
of a weekday I can be at the park with
my daughters yeah when they're young in
this precious moment versus the
conflicting and probably more powerful
sentiment which is like what are you
doing yeah what do you do with your life
man you have nothing going on and like
you're down here in the middle of the
day and you don't even know what you're
doing like this is not the way it's
supposed to look mm-hmm and that creates
a kind of vertigo yeah
the only way through that is to stay
with it and I think the answers are you
know within the self like Jesse knows
what the path is and those solutions
come when you can find those moments of
stillness and and clarity you know with
the clarity around those intuitions
comes when you carve out that time to
really connect with yourself and it's
it's not going to come from some other
person saying do this or don't do yeah
yeah that's true
and it kind of reminds me of in the
beginning of this conversation we were
talking about the power of marketing to
shift public perceptions when you're
talk about doping and Nike but the the
power of sports marketing to kind of
shift what masculinity looks like is
there - is these ideas that you're
describing having or are just like
inherited through right messaging yeah
that's what it is that's how they get
there whether it's from media or what
you saw from your own parents as kids or
whatever like they're not I don't know
they're not like Givens I guess and they
don't just exist for no Reno they're
just norm
their social contracts that are
reinforced through basically our daily
experience and everything that we see in
here and are exposed to so much in
happening with women right now in
marketing where they're the marketing
machine of business is for their own
sake to make money because it's hot
right now they're helping shift the
narrative around the feminine identity
uh-huh
and who's gonna be at the forefront from
a business side of shifting masculine
identity and capitalizing on that shift
because it's coming I think on a big way
it's happening around us but I just
wonder who's gonna which which who's
gonna be the first like male specific
company really jumping on that yeah
that'll be interesting well I don't know
I
Jesse's available sure I mean if he
wants to do that yeah I don't know he's
my inspiration well I mean he's a MIT
he's amazing and everything that you
guys are doing there's there's something
about I experienced this with my wife as
well like both of you guys have your
respective paths and kind of lanes that
you're in and you're excelling in those
and and you're very independent like in
and strong people but there's an alchemy
that when you come together whether it's
through your podcast or these other
various things that you do there's
there's something like exponentially
more awesome about that yeah I wish we
had more time to capitalize on that
together you know it's that's the nature
of young kids like right the age were a
bunch of people are splitting up they
got young kids this age and it causes so
much tension but I actually feel like
the podcast is like saving our marriage
we have this weekly time where we did
you change away that one plus one is
more than two uh-huh
when we're together and the formality of
the mics it just creates a structure
that forces you to be present yeah for
that you can't be like checking your
phone yeah whatever
thank you yeah so I have a joke with my
wife it's like oh I think we need to
like do a pod
because we gotta like time we need to
talk yeah yeah it's I don't know man I I
definitely feel like optimistic about
the future with Jesse I think it's
exciting I sometimes get jealous of
future us like if we can just make it to
future us where we have more time to
spend together with just us we just
gotta make it like four more years
because if we can make it four more
years still liking each other a lot
still loving each other we're gonna be
able to drop two kids off with someone
who will take them for a week or two
weeks or whatever we can do some cool
adventures together sometimes it feels
like I spend a lot of time admiring
Jesse from afar even though he's in my
home you know because there's so much of
like all right you take the kids I'm
gonna go out for a run I'll take the
kids you go out for your bike ride
you're leaving next weekend for this
work thing I'm leaving the next weekend
for this work thing you know we have we
get these short conversations and our
communication is good but we just don't
have that much time for depth so it's
yeah yeah it feels a little bit like
we're on hold sometimes well here's a
little tip yeah give me a by the time
you get to that point you're then you're
gonna lament you know that thing is do
you have to appreciate the moment that
you're in yeah because it is precious
and the kids do grow up so fast and all
of that future tripping your you know
takes you out of being present for what
is actually happening after all those
super advanced moments that are that are
hard but great and to the extent that
you can leverage them to cultivate
intimacy and and and grow closer to
Jesse like that's that's the beautiful
potential of the whole thing so that
when you get to that point where you can
drop them off you actually aren't gonna
want to yeah that too well what would
you write in your letter to your younger
self know that period of time
interviewing you I would say that so
many of the fears and anxieties were
completely like justifiable and
legitimate but also turned out to not
happen
and the amount of energy that I put into
them is you know ridiculous
so my letter would be to to to trust
yourself you know above all and to
invest the time required to get to know
who you are so that you can figure out
what that voice is trying to express and
be fearless in the expression of that
and if you can create fidelity to that
that your life will unfold in front of
you probably not the way you want it to
or on the timeline you would prefer it
to but that's really the only path you
know we're here to grow and to the
extent that you can invest yourself in
that personal growth I really think that
the answers that you're seeking are
revealed in that way yeah that's great
advice it makes me feel a little better
about the path I'm on but it also is
something have to constantly work like
recommit to because there's you know I
feel like that's my intention but then
life comes along and these you know
moments of choices but that's also how
you coach your athletes right it's
adaptability it's not about like here's
the plan and we have to be perfect
it's about being malleable mm-hmm so
that you can absorb whatever life is
throwing it yeah that requires a lot of
confidence yeah
adaptability requires confidence and I
think people look at you know like
you're on the cover of outside magazine
on a dock and like you have this
beautiful life and these beautiful kids
in this business and it all looks
fantastic and what I appreciate is just
the honesty with which you share or like
the struggles and how difficult it is
and I think it's fun to tune into your
podcast and there'll be questions about
like what gel do I use and then the next
question is like what is Venture Capital
it is kind of amazing the breadth of
things people write in that and it's fun
I really enjoy doing that I think you
need to write this book what do you
think what do you want to know in the
book what do I want to know what do you
want to know I just I think it to me it
almost doesn't matter like the narrative
is less important than just your voice
because there's something very specific
about the way that you write that's very
identifiable that dates all the way
- when you started blogging it's just
this unapologetic honesty that's so
refreshing so to me it almost doesn't
matter what you decide to focus on its
the voice I think yeah that that I
connect with and I think that's needed
you know especially like a strong female
voice who's honest who has integrity who
can speak truth to power and like
elevate you know the feminine the
strength and the feminine I think it's
something that we need in our culture
Thanks yeah so where we are with that
[Laughter]
you on this yeah you can press me on it
um I am obviously more committed than
ever to honest truth telling and my
writing style is to just say things how
they are and if I find that I'm dancing
around something I try to just cut right
into it and and get right to the truth
of the matter and so right now where I'm
at in the writing process it's kind of
recommit above I I was on a in a real
groove I'm sure any writer can relate to
this but in a real groove of writing
having it in my everyday and then
coaching started to ramp up and I host
these Wilder retreats or be running and
writing and those take a lot of time is
that women only because I want to go to
one of them you can come to the colors
I'm a Roman only what I do host them for
Parmenides Julia Hamlin still involved
yeah she was she's teaching the yoga at
the retreats she's awesome
yeah she what was I talking about
writing oh yeah writing so my book
milder yeah so I put it away I put it in
the drawer and then I recently was going
crazy because I'm not writing so I'm
spending time writing in my mind and my
bed pissed that I didn't write during
the day I'm at that stage of the
creative process but I needed to
essentially do a when when the track
season was over for the athletes I was
coaching I needed to kind of create
better boundaries around what my
coaching time is when my creative time
is what my family time is cuz all of
them were just bleeding into one another
and spending too much time on my phone
in front of my kids because I'm getting
coaching stuff coming in at 9 o'clock at
night and basically anything can pull
away from writing time because writing
is hard and you have to sit alone in a
chair
so suddenly I'm scheduling everything on
top of my writing time so I really did
that exercises sitting down and
reclaiming my time and now I have a
schedule so that's really help it's been
a week so let you know how it goes that
I am writing good again and just about
momentum yeah it is you know it is it's
like anything in that way how do you
deal with I'm sure you get this question
a lot like huh
you know you guys you're so you and
Jesse are so enmeshed in your your
business and your personal lives like
there's this idea like oh there needs to
be boundaries around like when we stop
talking about business and when it's
just our time and I just know for me per
like that's kind of like setting myself
up to fail because I can't really live
up to that
okay now we're here's the here's the
Iron Curtain that's going down on work
and it's like this is our lives like
this is what we're involved in this is
what's top of mind these are the things
we need to talk about so I don't do a
very good job in the traditional sense
of like creating boundaries around that
and I'm wondering how you guys do that
we've had to be pretty strict with it
and I think Jesse's like you I don't
think it's his natural inclination to
want to do it but I grew up in a
household that where boundaries weren't
really super safe
like my dad was an alcoholic he was an
amazing guy but he was kind of an
explosive alcoholic and so they I the
it's really important to me that they're
that there's going to be kind of like a
feeling of safety around what we're
going to talk about and with work work
is not safe for me talking about picky
bars at dinner or like I don't know just
having it kind of come out of left field
when I'm thinking about something else
it affects me in a really negative way
and part of that is the boundaries thing
from growing up but part of it is my
relationship with risk is so much
different from Jesse's and so every
conversation about picky bars comes back
to risk for me I mean our names are
cosine on every loan they could take our
house if picky buyers can't pay their
bills
that's normal entrepreneurship stuff
that Jesse's more comfortable with me
because of his upbringing and his
personality I grew up without a lot of
money and girls yeah so
I don't it's not safe it's not a safe
space that's so interesting so how did
you end up with such a like a stable
stand-up good dude she go to a lot of
therapy I have but after I met her I
think my mom used to tell me that she
hurt she grew up with an alcoholic dad
and she married an alcoholic and so I
knew from a young age that there was a
pattern and she told me straight up
don't marry an alcoholic plus we had a
lot of mental illness and our family and
especially bipolar disorder so all three
of my mom's siblings have or had bipolar
disorder when they were alive and so the
risk factors if you're genetically
predisposed you know alcohol and drug
use lack of sleep tons of stress so
those things I was aware of from a young
age too because my mom was the one kid
that managed to avoid that and she was
worried about my sister and I and so I
had this like double fear around alcohol
in particular so for me I really was
drawn to kids in high school had good
clean fun I spent a lot of time hanging
out with Mormons and Christians even
though I'm not a person of faith and
Jessi was sort of the first person I met
who was similar to me but not a person
of faith that was he didn't have his
first drink of alcohol until like two
months before his 21st birthday and he
got busted the first time he held a cup
in his hand at a college party ever
he got an MIP minor in possession which
was a state visit Stafford like
seriously that's the kind of luck so but
I was really attracted to the fact that
he he didn't need those things to be
himself or to be comfortable around
other people and I felt safe with him so
yeah I definitely tracked her beamed to
that secure stability yeah you transcend
it yeah I made it made it out yeah you
didn't step on the land mine and no did
you have to go did you go to al-anon
as a kid or anything like no and I was
just talking to my mom about that dad
never got sober no not well I don't know
maybe forced sober when he had liver
cancer because he couldn't drink when
you're on the you know chemo and stuff
but now you never he never did he was
high functioning I mean he always kept
his jobs and stuff but I think in that
industry there's a ton of alcohol use is
pretty common so yeah he never he never
did but I think there was there is some
element of that environment that I grew
up in that I missed though like all his
buddies were always they always had a
beer in their hand they were always down
to party they were always having fun
laughter yeah like for all that you know
when when it all falls apart is bad yeah
there's an aspect that's very exciting
it is it is very exciting you never know
what's gonna happen you don't you don't
know I do I am kind of that person in
the relationship not with substances but
I'm the livewire the unpredictable the
spontaneous one and Jesse's so stable
that sometimes we have friction around
that of like the predictable versus the
unpredictable you know but that - I'll
be able to roll with like you know money
is different I don't know there's
something about that well when you grow
up without it yeah you know yeah I'm
gonna have a different relationship with
it of course yeah that's true going to
Stanford like sports was my way out into
a different future right it I didn't get
a scholarship freshman year at Stanford
earned it but I was told when I went on
my recruiting chip that if I competed
well I'd get one every other year and
since I was young and naive I never
considered that wouldn't happen I never
considered a guy I'd get hurt or
anything I was like oh okay great so
that's as good as you telling me that I
only have to pay for first one part of
you know we got financial aid so one
part of one year and luckily I didn't
get hurt and I did get that support in
the other years and yeah so it it made a
difference but it always felt like
tenuous yeah like I would take ketchup
packets from fast-food restaurants
because I didn't have money to buy a
bottle of ketchup or I would buy my gas
like two dollars at a time just like
limping my car along I didn't have a
credit card or debit card like my
buddies on the team I couldn't do that I
had friends or giving me their old
hand-me-down clothes and I had friends
that would always magically buy me my
milkshake at post-race celebrations and
I got by with
a lot of support from people that I kind
of ways felt like had no business being
there so yeah that I didn't grow up with
any money management skills so yeah I
think Jesse had entrepreneurial parents
and just I think he just has a lot of
confidence and he went to business
school and he's just kind of I think
more familiar and I get better and
better he doesn't he's just realized he
has to really explain it to me and I
need to feel really safe I need all the
information but when I'm ready for it
and not it it's good you guys understand
that about each other because yeah you
can make sure that those needs are
fulfilled yeah right yeah and I think
every risk-taker kind of can benefit
from a voice of reason in their life so
I like to think that I I help keep picky
bars on like a more reasonable path of
risk course maybe a slightly more
conservative approach then he may
otherwise take only time will tell how
that turns out but we're almost done
yeah that's pretty good yeah yeah what's
where is it at like since I talked to
Jesse like how are you guys are in it
you guys you had like a couple supply
chain things we did sort of yeah and
when you talked to Jesse he was just
kind of Diamond in full-time to the
business after challenge wroth and kind
of decide he was gonna go on sabbatical
and apply his tenacity his iron person
tenacity to the business and he has had
an amazingly successful year so the
company is doing well we've had a few
profitable months nothing crazy but just
to like the models working he can see
clear year-over-year numbers that his
time and his effort has worked and that
the decisions we've made have been
beneficial and it feels good to see him
kind of walking around feeling proud of
himself for something so I'm not on
sport related that's cool and I do feel
safer and safer what I mean any time
you're in the black better yeah well a
decade in you've had ten years of
uncertainty and you guys are still doing
it so that should also you're probably I
still feel like our most profitable year
was when we were working out of our home
kitchen because your overhead is nothing
right you know it like we're selling
millions more picky bars but it's so
much harder to to make the numbers work
because it's the food business and just
business in general is just it doesn't
it still
doesn't totally make sense to me why
it's easy when you're tiny and then it's
almost impossibly hard until you get to
some magic number like ten million or
twenty million in revenue and then as
soon as you get there things start to
change again they'd scale in a different
way or I think a lot of businesses are
like that and my wife was in the fat in
the garment business and it was the same
thing like you when you're small it's
fine and then you get into that nether
zone that middle zone and she was she
had like a very complicated line and she
was doing all the store all the big
department stores and all that kind of
stuff but they you know their terms are
when they pay her were crazy and it's
like she was constantly teetering on
disaster yeah the whole time and you the
only way that you become like Tommy
Hilfiger is somebody gives you like an
insane amount of money to get you over
that yeah and that's the thing is that
we we are kind of at that level where we
have to decide do we try to find money
and try to grow it faster or do we kind
of stay the course on this safer more
sustainable path of growth we have all
positive signals in our business right
now but you know you know you don't know
you don't know so that's Jesse's job
that's what he's swimming in every day
and I'm like please don't bring me into
that unless you we have a meeting then
you have like 15 minutes to talk about
it right and yeah and he's like he's an
obsessive person you know does Ironman
you understand yeah so he could talk
about it 24/7 and be happy but mmm you
know he's I think it's good for I think
I forced him to be a little bit more
more balanced in that way all right we
gotta wrap this up all right a couple
minutes but I can't let you go without I
love asking elite athletes what they
what they would tell like what what are
the what are the things that most
amateurs are doing wrong like you're at
all these races marathons or whatever
5ks day and you see you're around a lot
of people who are weekend warriors or
serious amateurs and you're like why is
that person doing that don't they know
that they yeah like what comes up when
you think about that well being that I'm
in the food business I
generally I just had a moment like this
running a pickie bar booth at a at a
running event in Snohomish Washington
the things that come up to me the people
that think people say when they come to
a nutrition booth are just um that's why
it happens the most I'm like what why do
you think you cannot eat carbohydrates
why do you think that four grams of
sugar is too much sugar
why are you wishing this had zero
calories and its food it shouldn't have
like you know just the things that
people believe like hold these deep L
believes they make me sad because I just
know I know from experience having been
someone who teetered on the edge of an
eating disorder early in my professional
career who was pretty obsessed with with
weight and calories and trying to
optimize it like I did every other part
I was doing that from a performance side
but I know how much brain space it can
take up it makes you unable to really
enjoy your life and be present in so
many other ways so I just I see that and
I get sad because I'm just like oh
they're so imagine what you could do if
you weren't so worried about that 4
grams of sugar that comes from you know
banana managing what's possible
hence the I love carbs t-shirt yes in
defense of carbs say no I just I don't
know I I really do struggle with that
outside of that there's like kind of
more lighthearted things like people
just hammering or easy days I'm sure you
get that one a lot but when I go out and
runs with amateur runners that are just
they only run a few times a week but
when they do they hammer it I'm just
like move Strava culture yeah I do love
some good strong culture on the mountain
bike though I will confess but um yeah
you do you you just it's it's like
anything that people do that makes it
hard to have a sustainable enjoyable
relationship with sport is hard to see I
think I rather didn't weren't you
running with some Kenyans once and you
were like not so slow yeah I couldn't
believe it I really couldn't believe it
they were training in Palo Alto leading
into the paint and Jordan Invitational
to run 5ks and 10ks and I was just like
what is happening right now they were
doing the kind of job that you do when
you're approaching a red light and you
want to like time it so that you slow
way down so that you can hit the light
right when it turns brain so like how
slow 12 to 15 minute pace at
yeah like I'm talking for how long
before they ramp it up we're running 12
minute pace probably for a few minutes
and then sort of you just gradually
cranked it down then to 10 and then to 9
but I mean mind you at this time I was
running all my runs at 6:40 per mile
right 6 mins in 40 seconds so this was I
was like what's happening here I was
like jumped like tripping over my feet
and then by the end they were running
under six-minute miles I'm not
particular on they ran it like a
progression but when I later got to
train with Sally kPa go on her easy day
she would just run easier she would run
probably one and a half to two minutes
per mile slower than I would if I went
out by myself so I started making myself
go out with her the days after hard
workouts because she would just kick my
butt on the workout days on the truck
and like well obviously running those 9
minute miles isn't hurting you at all so
I might as well do that too there's some
kind of weird American mindset where
it's like we can't give ourselves
permission to do that I feel like if we
have this time we have to be you know
performance minded about it and yeah
it's squandered if we go slow yeah we
know it's a recovery day and that goes
for beyond sport right just taking the
15 minutes between when you got to the
doctor and your doctor appointment not
feel like you need to be checking emails
and answering I'm on your phone what if
you just sat there looked around I know
but all of man's suffering can be to
reduce to his inability to sit with
himself alone is that yeah yeah I will
say as a person new sitting still does
not come naturally to me but I had a
meditation practice for you I don't have
one if I was an early riser I would have
one easily
I want one but my kids are my alarm and
it makes it tough so I have to put it at
a different time of day it's not
impossible though I could do it but you
you live in this little blue zone right
like you're right on a river the kids
probably go to school like down the
street right you walk them or ride a
bike to school
yeah Jude's in first grade very
contained ladies home yeah it's a it is
it's a DS - yeah it's a T's - and so
I'll just you then she'd some Sixers
yeah first grader yeah learning to read
write doing all that super advanced he
hood so fun and what's so all right well
let's wrap this up so what's what would
I what's next like what do you like
what's next well top of mind for me is
really this is my new year's it's not
New Year's it's fall but I really want
to write I want to do creative work and
I want to be a part of my daily life I
want to be the best coach that I can be
and I want to spend more cut like
mindful present time with my family and
so I'm really trying to create three
distinct buckets I've lived my like an
integrated life approach that's what I
tend to do but I've just learned that
it's I'm it's really making me unable to
do those things as well as reaching
creativity and family yep that's what I
want to do and so creativity is gonna be
mostly my book but there's space for
music in there there's space for podcast
in there it's just like creating things
feeling like that creative part of me
that exists outside of someone else's
athletic success right because the
coaching is creative but it really is
for someone else's moments so and I have
as rewarding as that is I mean more than
that mmm good sellers yeah and I do I
want to set a better example for my kids
around device usage so that's where the
boundary comes for family that when I'm
with my family I want to be with my
family and I know Jesse and I are two
point in our relationship where I think
that will go a long way for us and in
for my first grader you know I want him
to I want him to know what we're doing
when we're in the room with him and when
your face isn't a phone you could be
doing anything yeah it's hard it's hard
though it is but I want to try it I'm
gonna try it for a few months and just
see what you know see what happens and I
think I just when I'm with Jesse and
we're not on our phones
I feel special so the most important
person in my life and so I know he must
feel the same way when I'm not on my
phone and I need that I need I need that
bolstered feeling that I matter to him
that he sees me and with all the other
things happening our life I need to feel
that and I want him to feel it yeah I
think that's a good place to end it yeah
beautiful beautifully thought I love
that and I'm gonna hold you to the book
I'm gonna be an early reader I'd be
happy to I love doing that yeah please
please any any help that I can give that
you're going to receive I appreciate it
awesome and then when you write it you
can come back and tell me about okay I'm
back on the show sounds great
work play love is the podcast you can
find Lauren she's easy to find on the
Internet Bushman flier Fleshman flyer
the grand grimoire and Fleshman on
Twitter on Twitter and you're not your
you blog on the was l site but not on
your own site no I haven't blogged on my
own site I want to revamp my website so
but ask Lauren Fleshman calm has
archives of kind of my athletic stories
and kind of some QA before we answered
questions on we play love
I answered questions on my blog right
cool yeah all right well a pleasure yeah
thank you so much it's been great
talking to you and I give my love to
Jesse will do carves peace and carbs
don't leave them out there sad
[Music]